[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce Yve livre Yve livre
très heureux puisque nous fêtons quelque
chose qui arrive rarement l'ouverture
d'une librairie bonjour od Marzin
bonjour vous êtes donc la libraire de de
cette nouvelle librairie qui que vous
avez ouverte à à plaisir oui tout à fait
et qui s'appelle plaisir de lire voilà
c'est tout simple c'est beau c'est bien
on sait de quoi il s'agit alors il y
avait plus de librairie à plaisir non il
y avait plus de librairie indépendante à
plaisir depuis la fin des années 2000 en
fait 2006 200007 ouis donc euh moi qui
habitait déjà plaisir à l'époque et qui
était déjà libraire à l'époque je l'ai
vu partir avec beaucoup de tristesse et
je me suis toujours promis qu'un jour je
reviendrai et voilà je reviendrai ouvrir
une librairie indépendante ça a mis du
temps mais euh et puis des rencontres
aussi et voilà donc 13 mai 2023 a vu la
concrétisation de ce rêve concrétisation
de ce rêve et l'ouverture de cette
libréie vous êtes deux oui tout à fait
exactement donc Lorna auoin et moi et VO
et vous alors vous avez aussi une
librairie à Paris c'est ça c'est ça donc
une librairie spécialisée jeunesse
nichée au cœur du 7e c'est un tout petit
écrin de 28 m²r que où l'orna est
majoritairement et c'est la librairie
Jila d'accord voilà et et ça se passe
bien à plaisir ah oui ça se passe très
très bien on a un accueil mais alors
absolument magique c'est les gens
passent le le pas de la porte juste pour
nous rencontrer pour nous voir pour nous
saluer pour nous remercier pour dire que
c'est c'est magnifique que c'est génial
que une librairie à plaisir ça manquait
tellement et on a même des gens qui
viennent de la ville d'à côté à pied
tous les samedis après-midi pour venir
acheter leur livres à la librairie c'est
bien ça ouis parce que c'est pas pareil
je pense qu'à plaisir il y avait des
grandes surfaces on peut trouver des des
livres mais c'est quand même pas la même
chose là on peut parler avec vous vous
pouvez conseiller vous pouvez dire voilà
j'ai lu ça c'est formidable ah oui et et
vous avez peut-être lu le lac au miroir
d'Udine le fr ah mais je l'ai même plus
que lu puisque je l'ai je l'ai vraiment
beaucoup aimé et il a fait partie
justement de l'histoire de de plaisir de
lire puisqueen fait c'est au moment où
j'ai commencé à faire l'Instagram et le
facebook de de la librairie en fait
alors avec le petit teasing hein et le
lac au miroir a été mon premier coup de
cœur que j'ai partagé en fait de la
rentrée littéraire de
de de de l'hiver et et odudil m'a très
gentiment contacté sur les réseaux et
après m'a envoyé un mail mais qui nous a
fait un plaisir immense et donc c'est
ainsi que nous sommes entrés entrés en
lien ça va
Lefranc oui ça va ça va Patrice CARM
c'est vous donc l'auteur de de de la au
miroir euh chez Viviane Amy grand
déductrice et c'est vrai à peu près
quand on quand on quand livre paraît
chez Vivian ami on pense que c'est on
peut pas savoir que c'est à peu près bon
généralement et puis on était vous étiez
déjà venu ici on avait parlé de de du
livre au moment de sa sortie ça fait
quelques mois maintenant oui ça va faire
9 mois bah ça fait 9 mois là qu'il est
sorti alors c'est un enfantement quoi
voilà
c'est vous réaccoucher si je
pe mais alors justement et vous serez
alors on va le dire tout de suite le 19
octobre on voit la fiche à à la
librairie plaisir de lire c'est à 19h
c'est ça donc une petite rencontre où
nous allons discuter toutes les deux du
livre le lac au miroir avec sa genèse
son écriture et et sa vie aussi depuis
qu'il est paru et suivi d'un petit verre
de l'amitié bien évidemment avec nos
chers clients est-ce que vous vous aimez
Bali vous je ne connais pas du tout Bali
mes parents ils sont allés quand j'étais
plus jeune et ils nous ont ramené des
photos qui m'avaient absolument fasciné
de la luxuriance de la nature et tout ça
mais non je n'ai pas eu la chance d'y
aller mais j'avoue très honnêtement que
quand j'ai refermé le livre j'avais bien
bien envie de prendre des m billets on a
envie d'y aller ou on a envie d'y aller
ouis parce que le le le livre se passe
pour une grosse partie he à Bali oui oui
ça se passe pratiquement sur deux
parties effectivement à Bali parce que
mon héroïne elle commence là-bas un peu
an Springer Anna Springer voilà elle est
un peu dans un vide existentiel et puis
elle repense à au tableau de son enfance
qui a horné les murs de sa chambre qui
étaient des tableaux peints par le
peintre
walterchpice et voilà et en fait elle
c'est alors Walter spit il il faut dire
qu'il a vraiment existé c'est c'est un
peintre musicien aussi d'ailleurs he oui
oui il a une vie incroyable il une vie
incroyable il a vécu à bal il a vécu à
Bali en fait il s'est carrément il a
choisi de vivre à Bali à partir de 1927
il a été invité par le prince du buudde
à l'époque c'était le premier Européen
faire une résidence d'artiste à Bali et
donc c'est en fait une vie incroyable
d'un artiste qui est un peu touche à
tout mais qui s'est vraiment concentré
ensuite sur la peinture et qui a
développé un mouvement pictural avec les
peintres balinés qui s'appelle le
mouvement pitamaha et qui existe encore
aujourd'hui enfin en tout cas on peut
encore voir des toiles et donc voilà mon
héroïne cherche héroïne voilà elle
arrive à bal alors elle apprend en même
temps la mort de sa mère he c'est ça
dont avec laquelle elle avit pas des
rapports très non non bah sa mère lui a
fait de lui a caché de nombreux secrets
notamment celui de son origine et donc
elle veut retrouver retrouver enquêter
un peu elle va enquêter sur sa mère mais
à partir de d'un tableau de Valter spis
qui a disparu s'appelle le lac au miroir
et qui est un peu la clé d'une énigme
familiale qui va emporter mon héroïne
sur les traces de sa mère et de
wterchpice adressde Bali Paris et voilà
donc on c'est une traversée de
l'histoire de le du 20e siècle en
quelque sorte mais aussi une quête des
origines à travers l'art et des secrets
et des secrets voilà secret deux
familles famor les fameux secrets de
famille Marzin alors
euh évidemment vous vous recevez
beaucoup de Liv oui un petit peu comment
comment vous faites vos choix vous lisez
pas tout vous pouvez pas tout lire on
peut malheureusement pas tout lire non
désolé mais c'est c'est vrai bon nous à
la librairie plaisir de lire nous sommes
deux donc Véronique et moi plus notre
Léa notre apprenti donc on essaie de se
partager les lectures histoire de de de
balayer au maximum la rentrée littéraire
comme là et dit le front vous êtes tombé
comment de de se al en fait ça a été ça
a été en fait euh une réunion de de de
libraire au mois de décembre une
présentation qui été fait VO voilà mais
là c'est dans le cadre de page des
libraires qui est une revue de libraires
ou ouais et donc bah je suis allé
assister comme on avait la le comment le
le projet de l'ouverture de plaisir de
lire du coup on est allé pour se
renseigner elle est très très belle
magnifique ah pierre Gimenez notre
architecte a fait un excellent travail
on doit le dire il nous a mais vraiment
fait ça aux petits oignons mais alors
conocté magistralement et euh et donc du
coup lors de la présentation après à la
sortie on a on peut demander plusieurs
services presse et tout ça et donc
j'avais demandé le lac au miroir parce
que l'histoire m'avait interpellé pour
des tas de raisons surtout les les
histoires de secret de famille et tout
ça voilà ça m'a ça avait fait un petit
écho donc je me suis dit ah tiens et
quand je l'ai reçu la couverture m'a
beaucoup beaucoup intrigué la l'objet
puis en plus le vernis sélectif sur le
dessus enfin bon voilà on a un côté très
charnel avec les enfin moi j'ai un côté
s charnel avec les livres et euh et donc
je l'ai je l'ai lu enfin je l'ai ouvert
je l'ai dévoré en 2 jours même pas ah
oui et je l'ai fait lire à Lorna et on
s'est dit wou c'est trop génial il est
trop bien et tout lui il sera sur la
table à plaisir de lire ça c'est sûr
donc du jour de l'ouverture depuis
l'ouverture le livre a ma petite notule
sur sur le sur la table de la libririe
plaisir de lire ça fait ça fait du bien
d'entendre ça ou mais c'est
extraordinaire vous savez parce que le
livre il il a fait un long parcours
avant d'arriver oui sur une table de
librairie prierom et c'est mon premier
roman qui est voilà qui m'a demandé 6
ans de travail et puis après quand enfin
quand j'ai vu que Hae avait fait un coup
de cœur sur les réseaux forcément j'ai
je lui écrit je lesai remerciis et puis
j'ai découvert qu'elle lançait cette
librairie donc j'ai en fait ce que
j'aime beaucoup c'est que ils ont tout
un travail de de autour de la lecture à
plaisir mais aussi avec les écoles
et c'est ceà dis tout à l'URE c'est que
il y c'est des gens qui lisent c'est des
gens qui aiment c'est des gens qui
conseillent et participer à cette
aventure là moi ça c'est voilà c'est
quelque chose qui est très important
pour moi d'aller à la rencontre des
lecteurs mais aussi de partager aussi
voilà la manière dont on écrit un livre
ça prend du temps c'est un autre temps
que les réseaux sociaux et puis c'est
aussi le de retrouver le temps de la
lecture et puis de rencontrer des
personnes comme comme autes qui sont
tellement habités par leur m la passion
de la lecture mais aussi du métier de
libraire
je me dis que c'est une chance vous
voyez parce que 9 mois dans une
librairie c'est parce que parce que
quand on écrit on est enfermé on est
seul on on sait pas évidemment on fait
du mieux possible et et mais on sait pas
quelles vont être les réactions hein et
c'est vrai que moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir de nombreux coups de cœur de
libraire d'être aussi dans des prix de
lecteurs donc mon livre je pense qu'il a
il a il a fait son petit chemin il fait
son petit chemin il heureusement ça ça
existe encore justement avec des des des
peut-être des des des éditrices comme
Vivian am dire laisser du temps au livre
alors justement Vivian amis c'est donc
elle est aussi animée par cette maison
d'édition par l chastelou qui a un peu
repris les reennes de cette maison et
c'est vrai que mon éditrice c'est lis
chastelou viian am a mon livre non mais
ce sont les éditions VII am mais
voilà fa je veux dire l'esprit de cette
maison de là c'est en effet c'est
parfois on a des trucs c'est des c'est
conettes comme ça l'immédiaté et c'est
terrible pour le livreou et moi en tant
que libraire enfin je sais que justement
j'ai pas du tout ce cette politique là
et cette cette vie là moi pour moi les
les livres je l'ai fait vivre sur alors
c'est peut-être parce que je je suis une
libraire spécialisée jeunesse donc je
peux me permettre d'avoir des livres
très très longtemps sur les étagères
puisque tous les ans j'ai des enfants
qui apprennent à lire tous les ans j'ai
des enfants qui fêtent leur 10 an et que
on peut leur proposer d'autres choses et
en fait nous on a vraiment cette
politique là pour pour la littérature
Mme
nous on souite faire venir à la
librairie des auteurs qui ne seront pas
en promotion actuelle ex la preuve le
livre est sorti il y a 9 mois et c'est
le 19 octobre que vous
venez c'est un souit de not part ouais
c'est un souhait de notre part c'est
vraiment d'aller vers des auteurs qui
ont peut-être eu leur leur succès au
moment où le livre est paru et tout ça
et où bah les ventes commencent à
s'essouffler et tout ça et redonner un
petit coup de projecteur au livre et à
l'auteur ouais c'est et bien et ça nous
permet aussi nous ça nous permet aussi
de faire découvrir le livre en amont et
que l'auteur quand il vienne en fait il
a déjà des lecteurs devant lui en fait
absolument et ça c'est intéressant parce
que c'est très enrichissant la rencontre
avec les gens qui ont déjà lu un Liv ça
ça vous êtes arrivé vous avez fait
beaucoup de de je pense de salons de oui
j'en ai fait une trentaine et alors bah
c'est toujours émouvant parce qu'en fait
à chaque fois d'abord il y a le la
rencontre avec les lecteurs et puis ils
ont des questions qu'on retrouve parfois
comment on écrit un premier roman
comment on se fait éditer est-ce que
vous êtes est- est-ce que c'est de la
fiction est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est vous le personnage et puis après
on se laisse emporter par la la
formidable vie de wter Spice et puis
aussi de cette quête des origines donc
c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois bah je je je
suis toujours ravi de de pouvoir parler
de de ce qui a créer l'origine aussi de
ce livre ce livre et
et est-ce qu'il y a aussi ce que ce que
disait out c'est dire des des gens qui
l'ont lu qui sont qui échangent avec
vous oui oui bien sûr parce que quand on
va en librairie justement parfois des
personnes l'ont déjà lu
donc ils ont des questions très très
précises sur le sur le texte sur le
livre sur Valter spi sur ce tableau
disparu donc il fautut faut donner des
réponses sans sans spoiler sans c'est ça
divulgaché c'est
extrêmement c'est extrêmement compliqué
pour avoir fait une rencontre justement
au mois de septembre avec Gael Noan dont
le livre pareil est sorti au mois de
janvier l'année enfin janvier 2023 en
parler sans en dire plus parce qu'il y
avait très peu de gens qui l'avaient lu
dans dans l'assemblée c'était
extrêmement compliqué parce qu'on on
marche sur les œufs et même les
personnes qui l'avaient lu ne voulit pas
trop en dire non plus donc vous me
comprenez si je vous dis que voilà voilà
mais c'est très intéress P c'est les
polar ah alors là on en parle même pas
si on aime pas l'auteur on dit c'est
machin qui a tué voilà mais justement 19
octobre comment ça pardon comment ça va
se
passer est là elle il y a des livres
elle signe et elle parle alors fait
exactement elle va parler parce qu'en
fait nous on fait vraiment une une
rencontre c'est-à-dire que c'est une
rencontre ououi tout à fait c'est une
rencontre on va on va échanger on va
échanger toutes les deux autour du livre
et et après on va voir si les personnes
présentes souhaitent poser des questions
ou quoi que ce soit et puis après on
passera à une séance de dédicace et
comme je disais après le verre de
l'amitié bien
entenduentendu c'est quoi la première
question que vous lui poseriez
ah c'est pas encore préparé si si si si
elle est préparée mais j'ai pas encore
décidé l'ordre des questions mais je
pense que ce serait pourquoi wter oui
pourquoi W SP que honnêtement moi je je
je n jamais entendu parler de lui avant
de
dire je suis allé sur
Google exement il y avait trop de
détails pour pour
qu'ilsument mais mais bon comme c'est
une fiction aussi
hein on aurait pu avoir un peintre de de
fiction non c'est c'est un vrai ce qui
ce qui ajoute d'ailleurs à la qualité du
du je crois du du roman ah bah oui
complètement donc voilà rencontre avec
les lecteurs c'est évidemment pour vous
c'est c'est formidable et et et pour ha
aussi c'est un événement il y aura
d'autres événements comme oui alors on
est pour le moment on est parti un petit
peu sur le rythme d'une rencontre par
mois ouais c bien parce que c'est déjà
une préparation et que il faut pas non
plus épuiser nos nos lecteurs avec des
des rencontres toutes les semaines et
tout ça je pense que une par mois c'est
pas mal donc donc jeudi prochain od nous
fait l'honneur de de venir à la
librairie le mois prochain au mois de
novembre le 19 16 novembre pardon jeudi
16 novembre ce sera Jennifer leessieur
qui vient nous voir pour
rosevallent qui est paru aux édition
Robert Lafond mais précédemment chez to
elle avait fait un titre en fait où
était mis en scène la forêt domaniale de
plaisir puisque en fait elle est
plaisiroise elle est plaisiroise elle
est plaisiroise donc elle va venir elle
va venir de Lyon pour sur sur ces TER
natal pour parler de de on va essay de
la rencontrer à cette occasion là
écoutez le 16 novembrevembreou tout à
fait alors euh vous êtes venu très
gentiment déjà mais très gentiment je
fini ma phrase avec quelques conseils de
de de lecture de lecture oui des livres
qui sont qui viennent de sortir et qui
pour moi seront sur lestbl de la de la
librairie avec ma petite notule mon
petit coup de cœur et et puis mon
accompagnement aussi parce que ce sont
des auteurs que j'aime beaucoup que je
ne connaissais pas pourtant il a il a
beaucoup écrit mais je ne le connaissais
pas c'était Jean-Michel guacia donc pour
ce titre adieu VAT qui vient de sortir
chez Albin Michel qui est bah tout est
dans le titre pour qui parle un petit
peu le Breton adieu VAT c'est un peu sur
la fatalité c'est un peu aller à Jas
adieu VAT voilà c'est c'est comme ça ça
se passe entre Paris et la Bretagne
l'histoire de trois femmes quatre
enfants dont le destin va être
irrémédiablement lié par une enfance
vraiment soudée mais ils sont tous
d'origine différente donc au moment de
la
puis la guerreiale vont venir un petit
peu bousculer tout ça et et c'est c'est
passionnant ça se ça se dévore et et on
on a beaucoup de tendresse pour les
personnages c'est bien c'est chez Albin
Michel hein c'est chez Albin Michel oui
tout à fait alors celui-là il aura une
petite notu il a déjà sa petit notule il
a déjà sa not le grand feu de Léonor des
Rondo chez Grassé moi Léonor des Rondo
je l'avais déjà rencontré précédemment
sur pietre viiva que j'avais déjà
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup après
elle a écrit aussi amour enfin elle a
fait plusieurs textes et ce que j'aime
dans sa plume c'est qu'elle a une plume
mais qui vous embarque complètement qui
vous fait vibrer de de tout ici par le
grand feu on est au 17e siècle à Venise
la Pieta est un une une institution en
fait tenue par une communauté de sœurs
qui accueille les orphelins qui surtout
toutes les filles en fait les orphelins
ou les bébés abandonnés et toutes les
filles sont voué à la musique d'accord
leur maître de musique n'est rien
d'autre
que oui Vivaldi tout à fait
touours
ave c'est Vivaldi merci et et en fait
Haria l'héroïne elle n'est ni orpheline
ni abandonnée en fait sa mère c'était
était enceinte d'elle quand elle est
allé écouter une messe elle a dit si
c'est une fille je la je l'avouré
comment à la piéa donc elle l'a remise à
la piéa et l'enfant vit bercé par la
musique et le jour de ces 6 ans on va
lui remettre un petit violon dans les
bras et elle va s'embraser complètement
en en jouant de la musique c'est par le
grand feu et donc elle savait être la
passion avec la musique elle va devenir
les petites mains de de Vivaldi c'est
elle qui recopie ses ses partition et
tout ça et elle a une amie qui elle ne
fait pas partie de la Piéta mais comme
ses parents sont font partie de
l'aristocratie lui paye des cours de
musique à la Piéta et cette cette jeune
fille va la faire venir chez elle et
elle a un grand
frère génial voilà dit c'est incroyable
parce que tout le monde connait lual
évidemment en même même sur les
répondeur téléphoniqu mais jusqu'au 20
siè on avait totalement oublié quoi on
l' redécouvert dans les mais c'est et sa
musique est tellement actuelle tellement
vive et actuelle tout çaant 3 siècles on
on l' pratiquement oublié quoi voilà et
donc lon elle est italienne pas du tout
elle est française c'est une autrice
française et elle est
vraiment oui mais oui oui je l'ai jamais
rencontré donc je n jamais voilà
exactement mais elle a fait d'autres
titres qui se pass qui se passent
ailleurs et tout ça mag comme je suis
quand même une une libraire jeunesse je
ne pouvais pas manquer de ne parler d'un
de mes livres énorme coup de cœur donc
sur Louise Michel je suis tout en orage
de Carole Trebor qui est paru dans une
collection que j'adore tout
particulièrement la collection destin
chez Albert Michel lit donc jeunesse euh
et j'ai eu la chance c'est pour les pour
les jeunes enfin oui ah oui c'est à
partir de de 11 12 ans sans problème
parce qu'en fait on va voir Louise
Michel de sa jeunesse en fait on va la
voir enfant on va voir toutes les
graines qui vont qui vont
exactement et touses combats parceen
fait c'était une femme très
avantgardiste elle elle était contre la
maltraitance des enfants et des femmes
mais également la maltraitance animale
elle a lutté sur les barricades à Paris
elle elle a risqué sa vie pour sauver un
chaton donc c'est voilà et à côté de ça
elle va prendre la vie d'un homme donc
voilà
c'est com et et Carole trbor ou et
Carole trbor est une historienne et on
sent vraiment toute la la richesse de de
de de de son écriture et tout ça et moi
cette collection là je je l'aime
énormément il y en a il y a beaucoup de
titres maintenant qui sont parus et à
chaque fois on a une personnalité que ce
soit Marie curry ou même Mohamed Ali ou
enfin on va
V ici on a passé 13 ans ou 14 ans quand
même moi moi j'ai a pris un plaisir
énorme mais ça c'est c'est justement
l'avantage de cette collection c'est que
c'est famoi ah mais complètement et
alors il y en avait un qui était sorti
bah le précédent de Carole Trébor dans
la collection c'était combien de pages
jusqu'à la lune qui a raconté l'histoire
de Catherine Johnson cette
mathématicienne noire américaine qui a
qui a calculé le comment le retour de de
Apollo 11 sur sur ouais ouais le retour
de Neil Armstrong et des astronautes en
fait dans la capsule et c'est elle qui
l'a calculé donc c'est un destin mais
fabuleux et donc voilà et donc là elle
elle nous a fait connaître un petit peu
plus Louise Michel tout à fait ah oui un
un livre un roman que je recommande très
chaleureusement et là vous avez un album
sublime ah oui vous l'avez vu vous le
connaz je
découv très très bel album et en plus
qu'il y a une histoire un petit peu
particulire de G c'est ça les neuf vies
extraordinaire de la princesse Gaia paru
aux éditions little urban donc il vient
tout juste de sortir il est sorti la
semaine dernière euh en fait le
l'origine du projet c'est l'illustrateur
Régis lejon qui a eu une idée de faire
naître une princesse la princesse Gaia
qui va changer de nom suivant sa vie et
il a proposé à neuf auteurs de lui
écrire une vie et donc en fait chaque
auteur a eu une période donc ça peut
être la Chine médiévale ça peut être
l'Amérique du Sud un petit peu plus tard
période et lieux complètement
différentes et donc on va suivre Gaia
comme ceci à travers à travers tous ces
toutes ces vies et avec des
illustrations qui sont absolument
magnifiques voilà parce que donc c'est
neuf auteurs mais un un seul
illustrateur donc on a une unité au
niveau des au niveau des des
illustration et et quand on voit les les
plumes c'est ce sont des belles plumes
de la littérature de jeunesse puisque on
a Annie Agopian Fred Bernard Anne Coré
Alex Cousseau Anne Jonas Henry meunier
Guilen roman Cécile rouiger et Thomas
sot donc voilà ça c'est alors quel âge
ça c'est quand même un album pour assez
grand on est quand même sur du 7 et plus
7 et plus ouis c plus quand même mais
c'est un bel objet pour Noël à offrir à
Noël c'est vraiment magnifique parce en
plus vous allez avoir autant de
d'information historique que que
civilisation en fait de civilisations
différentes des mythologies différentes
et et on en apprend énormément et on le
trouve évidemment à plaisir de lireit ça
c'est oui parce que c'est c'est
bien c'est c'est il y a une belle
littérature pour jeunesse qui est très
vivante he d'Illes très très vivante et
beaucoup de d'originalité beaucoup de
oui oui et puis on a des plumes
actuelles en littérature de jeunesse qui
sont absolument que vraiment qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qui fait un bon livre de jeess
je dirais l'originalité les personnages
et comment
Leit l'écriture aussi ouais à moi il y a
des auteurs et autrices que je suis
vraiment très très particulièrement mais
vraiment de tous les livres et en
général comme je disais j'aime beaucoup
les les premiers romans parce que ça me
permet de découvrir une une plume et
après j'aime bien suivre ce qui est ce
qui est fait derrière parce que ce que
disait je crois Michel Tournier qui
disait le le le le le plus beau style
c'est c'est enfin le meilleur style
c'est quand on arrive à écrire justement
pour la pour la jeunesse parce que les
les enfants sont très exigeants ils sont
très exigant les enfant et c'est vrai
que
c'est c'était le plus qu' disait être le
plus difficile et quand il arrivait à ça
il était heureux ah oui oui non mais en
plus c'est quand même l'auteur de de
vendredi la vie sauvage qui est quand
même un des non mais il savait écrire
pour les enfants et pour les adultes
d'ailleurs mais mais il disait que
c'était là où il était le plus heureux
c'est quand il arrivit à écrire
justement pour mais quand on échange
quand on échange justement avec des
auteurs de de jeunesse qui écrivent en
jeunesse ils le disent ils sont des fois
plus heureux et plus plus épanouis en
littérature de jeunesse parce que les
retours qu'ils ont sont tellement
spontanés et tellement naturel et puis
euh et puis ce sont ce qu'on appelle
alors j'aime pas ce termelà mais ce sont
des longues selleurs si vous avez un
livre qui fonctionne très très bien vous
pouvez l'avir exactement moi mon livre
mon livre préféré de que j'ai lu en
jeunesse je l'ai lu en 2014 et il est
toujours sur mon étagère et j'en vends
toujours toujours toujours c'est le
livre 1414 de C Edgar et Paul beor nos
éditions castelm et c'est un livre pour
moi c'est un livre qui convient aussi
bien aux enfants qu'aux adultes adultes
et j'ai même quand j'ai eu la chance de
recevoir les auteurs en dédicace et
quand ils sont venus j'ai une dame qui
est venue pour acheter pour sa mère ah
oui donc il y a la grand-mère elle et
leur petit la petite fille avait lu le
même livre et c'est c'est un livre qui
est qui est génialissime form elle est
formidable hein ah ouis hein elle est
passionante ou vous avez passé une
soirée incroyable le 19 octobre sera un
vrai plaisir vous vous vous êtes sur
quoi là d si je peux dire ah ben
j'essaie de de de commencer un manuscrit
ouais ouais ouais ah ouais j'essaie
c'est c'est facile qu on fait là en ce
moment je dois dire que c'est pas
forcément évident parce que je suis
toujours en train de parler du miroir
donc je suis toujours dans l'univers il
va falloir l'abandonner à un moment
c'est tristeou c'est triste ouais ouais
ouais l'abandonnez pas tout de suite en
tout cas vous l'abandonnerez pas le 19
octobre puisque vous serez à la à la
librairie plaisir de lire bah merci
beaucoup merci le fr merci beaucoup
Marzin et et bravo enfin bravo pour
bravo vous pour le lac au miroir et
bravo pour plaisir de lire cette
librairie quand même formidable d'ouvrir
une librairie aujourd'hui hein c'est un
rêve je crois de ça fait rêver ça fait
rêver merci à toutes les deux merci
[Musique]
merci